Peter bone if David Cameron what's these
debates why doesn't he just say okay I
agree to what's been proposed well he
just want a debate I mean we know he
does want the debate you said it time
time again everybody hasn't agreed so
the timing is ridiculous I mean how
could you have a debate on the thirtieth
of April when a quarter of the voters
who were already voted by post that be
pointless you need to have them earlier
that's what the prime minister said now
is only today that I understand mr.
bilham and has agreed to it I mean he
was the one holding up the debate all in
the green shouldn't be involved III
don't know and he said complete message
should have been shorted out months ago
so don't have election debates during
the election campaign look I've been on
this program so many times have a like
saying I never thought these debates
would happen because David Cameron
doesn't want them to happen he's never
wanted them happen he was always going
to make whatever excuse he could to
wriggle out at them first of all there
was the Greens then it was not how you
you and a lot of desert about having
read it was not having the camera is not
having a short campaign so we have
always been completely relaxed about the
format we accepted the original format
we accept the revised format with now
accepted a new format I think it's
pretty obvious to the degree of British
people here you have a prime minister
incredibly who's not prepared to subject
himself to these debates because he's
running scared and the British people
will take their own judgment from that
okay Tim Shipman I mean who was his
debate and who's running from them in
your being led bill of our monster
debates and David Cameron doesn't want
the debates but if I might be so bold as
to offer a slight suggestion that the
broadcaster's themselves are not
entirely blameless here and I wrote a
story nearly a year ago saying that
David Cameron except you know the debate
including the greens and they had to be
before the campaign starts what has been
presented instead are debates that will
initially not fit the greens now do
feature the Greens to leaked proposals
darling saying I don't I do not
understand this why you can't have
election debates during the election
campaign well I think pink has made a
point that's valid that you know postal
voting will start earlier but that posle
was for three debates two of which would
have taken place before postal voting
well indeed that's why I hate that my
septic but the head but broadcasters
have made it too easy for David Cameron
to get out of this it has been known for
over a year he turned up at a press
gallery lunch in 2012 and said if we're
going to have debates they have to be
before the campaign kick
and the proposals that been put there
made it far too easy for him to get out
there everyone knows he wants to wriggle
out of this if he gets in a car and
heads to the debates Lynton Crosby is
going to stage a car crash to prevent
that from happening and yet everything
that's been presented time and time
again you know the suggestion we now got
with 27 way debates or the 28 about even
the lib dems don't like that that puts
them on this on a par with planet camry
Farage is not happy for you kids like
well that's hardly the case but they say
we've been a party government and we you
know they regard themselves as grander
than that Farraj wants to take places
that you know that the one guy chucking
rocks for the angle people in mastering
this are the viewing public and their
vote exactly is that and you Peter Berg
you think these debates should take
place for that very reason oh absolutely
you cannot once you've started leaders
debates and they're a good that you
can't put them back the fact that we're
in this message I mean seven way to big
debates are nonsense what we should have
had his head head debates between David
Cameron and Ed Miliband had them earlier
and everyone would have been happy how
we've allowed it to get to this MIT and
I think Tim said the media's got a bit
to do I mean as a former broadcaster do
you think the negotiators and I said
well I'm not one of them have made a
mess of it I think the broadcaster's
have been very naive about the
Conservatives intentions which were
never to take part in these debates the
broadcaster's should be much tougher be
you're absolutely right these are the
people's debates and we still do have
independent broadcasters in this country
it's never been up to the politicians
did it take the format or the cast list
the broadcaster's should have stuck to
their guns originally they should stick
to their guns now and if necessary they
should empty chair David Cameron soaked
in I mean whatever the rights and wrongs
do you think today's developments make
the debates more or less likely I don't
think it makes the blondest but a
difference what will what will change
whether they happen is where the David
Cameron finds themself eight points
behind with a fortnight to go then you
might see some debates but at that point
ed Miliband might not want them you
really think it's all about that's all
about advantage it's not it's not about
I mean we do know that the electorate
are turned off politics we do know that
the implication of Timothy what was the
last time I mean surely that should come
first ahead of party advantage well I
mean I spent time as you have I been
reported in the United States I don't
think this should be in the hands of the
politicians or the broadcaster's I think
there should be an end
body that negotiates and says this is
what we're doing and then neither side
can wriggle out of it but which I do
have interpreted as the politicians have
got to agree to be bound by the inaction
but what I mean I'd really don't accept
this premise that David Cameron does not
want to debate David Cameron all opinion
polls is two-thirds ahead to one-third
from Miliband as Prime Minister he's far
better at debating why would he not want
to do cause he wants because he's
risking that Peter if if he goes but
Israeli Prime Minister Prime Minister's
Questions you know any fair observer
would say that you know if you're giving
the advantage to Cameron he wins three
weeks out of 5 and you know he might
turn up and have a bad day you know he
didn't do brilliantly well in the first
debate last time that actually probably
prevented him from getting majority ed
Miliband is a perfectly good debater and
expectations of him are so very low well
that's it if he turns up and doesn't
fall flat on his face then that argument
that you're advancing that the
Conservatives have a better leader is
god that's why they should take place I
mean could it be the idea man there's
nothing nothing to lose than if he was
further ahead he wouldn't want to debate
as Tony Blair indeed well I think the
decline the president was set last time
and it's very difficult as everyone has
acknowledged to put the book to put the
clock back of every cameraman what he's
trying but we do have independent all
casters in this country have thank God
unlike in Russia independent broadcasts
who should be standing firm and Tim so
the implication what Tim has said about
while Cameron would do it if he was
eight points behind implies that
everything he said about oh I want this
place to hang them caller but I can
acknowledge vehicle 30 the eight ball is
the wrong day not after 25 is everything
everything is said upon what I'm gonna
do that's what you have not been true
he's never wants to do that all right
Tim if it comes to it and we don't get
an agreement this side of the start of
the election campaign what do you think
the broadcaster should do should they
say okay we accept we've been beaten at
this one debates off or should they say
we will go ahead and staged these three
scheduled debates two weeks apart from
the beginning of April to the end
irrespective of whether Cameron turns
out my personal view would be that the
7-way debates could go ahead is six way
debates and that would still be
interesting for the public unfortunately
a to a debate without one of the people
is not a debate it's an interview
so do you think if they don't get
agreement should they go ahead or not
right we should get agreement that
should be earlier and the Prime Minister
and Ed Miliband to debater it's as
simple as that absolutely the
broadcaster should have prep should put
a chair there with a teddy bear and say
this is where the prime minister should
be but his for it ok to leave me thank
you very much indeed